[Música]
y
pese a que ucrania está muy distante de
américa latina' la invasión de rusia a
este territorio y también la guerra
desatada tiene efectos muy complejos en
nuestra región la destrucción del
aparato productivo ucraniano también la
incapacidad para cumplir con las
exportaciones de cereales como trigo y
maíz así como la pérdida de cosechas ha
provocado una especie de tensión mundial
por el acceso a esos cereales por ende
también ha habido un incremento en los
precios y desabastecimiento entre otros
factores si algo ha dejado en evidencia
esta crisis ucraniana es las enormes
diferencias que hay en la producción de
alimentos en américa latina' en nuestra
región que podría producir alimentos
para abastecerse prácticamente a toda la
población de nuestros países pero debido
a sus desigualdades también a los
factores climáticos a los factores
políticos y técnicos como lo prevé el
programa de alimentos en américa latina'
atravesará una aguda crisis de
inseguridad alimentaria veamos las
cifras de acuerdo con este programa
mundial de alimentos antes de la
invasión de rusia a ucrania cerca de 9,3
millones de latinoamérica ya sufrían
inseguridad alimentaria ahora con el
transcurso de la invasión y el
recrudecimiento del conflicto se espera
que la cifra de latinoamericanos que
sufren inseguridad alimentaria llegue al
13 3 millones de personas
pero ustedes se preguntarán por qué
incide rusia y ucrania en todo esto pues
rusia es el país agresor y también es el
cuarto mayor productor mundial de trigo
y debido a las sanciones internacionales
no puede comercializar totalmente su
producción
ucrania es el séptimo productor a nivel
mundial y por la guerra pues tampoco
puede cumplir con sus compromisos
internacionales ante este escenario otro
país india para terminar este triángulo
es el tercer país productor de cereales
a nivel mundial y prohibió las
exportaciones de los cereales de todas
sus cosechas para poder garantizar su
consumo interno el escenario entonces
llevó a que los precios de los alimentos
por lo menos en américa latina' hayan
aumentado entre un 8 y el 13 por ciento
también la guerra ha llevado a que el
costo de los fertilizantes que son
elaborados en rusia y en belarús y que
son popularmente comercializados en
américa latina' hayan aumentado sus
precios en un 300% lo que dificulta la
producción de alimentos en la región de
américa latina'
entonces pues queda muchas preguntas
sobre la mesa estamos o no ante una
posible crisis humanitaria o alimentaria
mejor en nuestra región es posible
mitigar su impacto vuelve a quedar
también sobre la mesa el debate de esas
enormes desigualdades que hay en américa
latina' es el modelo de producción la
respuesta es también esa deficiente
infraestructura también uno de los
puntos que nos juega en contra y también
esa desigualdad que hay en cuanto al
reparto de las tierras en una región
donde como ya lo decía se podría
producir diferentes tipos de alimentos
para alimentar prácticamente a todos sus
habitantes podríamos ser entonces
autosuficientes como región son muchas
las preguntas ante este posible
escenario de una crisis alimentaria en
américa latina' lo vamos a analizar hoy
en el debate de france 24 y para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a expedito nastro él es oficial del
programa mundial de alimentos es
analista en seguridad alimentaria se
encuentra en ciudad de panamá panamá y
también según esta conversación miguel
garcía y hacerles director regional para
centroamérica de la ong acción contra el
hambre él se conecta desde
de managua en nicaragua ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de esta
conversación estamos a través de las
diferentes redes sociales facebook
instagram twitter y también pueden ver
nuestras señales en streaming en youtube
no se encuentra como france24 y un bajo
ese también como arroba santi logo que
es mi cuenta personal y nuestra etiqueta
es numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas
relacionados con este tema comienza
entonces dándole la palabra a nuestro
invitado en ciudad de panamá les la
bienvenida a expedito nastro expedito
gracias por estar con nosotros un gusto
tenerlo hoy en el programa y punto de
partida como me gusta llamar a esta
primera pregunta que lanzó para abrir el
debate el punto de partida es si estamos
a la vuelta de la esquina de una posible
crisis alimentaria en nuestra región si
o no
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación y
para la oportunidad de hablar de un tema
que nos preocupa mucho como programa
mundial de alimentos como mencionaba
antes en la presentación la región de
américa latina del caribe está
atravesando una crisis que es el
resultado de lo que nosotros definimos
una emergencia compleja y silencios al
mismo tiempo compleja porque hay varios
factores que están contribuyendo al
mismo tiempo a impactar negativamente la
seguridad alimentaria de las personas
que viven en la región primero tenemos
que mencionar que esta región ha sido
una de las más afectadas por la pandemia
que en los últimos años ha impactado
negativamente la capacidad de esas
personas de generar ingresos y de
satisfacer las necesidades básicas
la pandemia se ha traducido también en
efectos inflacionarios
que se han visto amplificados por el
conflicto el impacto que ese conflicto
ha tenido en los mercados globales y en
particular por el aumento del costo de
algunas de algunos productos claves para
la economía como el combustible los
fertilizantes y las materias primas como
el aceite vegetal y en general el precio
de la comida bueno pues ya veníamos
entonces arrastrando una crisis
económica a raíz de la pandemia de kobe
19 y ahora esto este conflicto no crea
ni ha venido entonces a potenciar un
poco esa crisis punto de partida para
miguel garcía arias también le doy la
bienvenida al programa desde la ciudad
de managua en nicaragua miguel adelante
estamos a la vuelta de la esquina de una
posible crisis alimentaria si o no
si de hecho ya lo estamos y sobre todo
en algunos países países como guatemala
como honduras donde la inseguridad
alimentaria forma parte cotidiana de la
vida de millones de personas
respecto a las cifras también hay que
matizar que la situación antes de
iniciar este proceso inflacionario y el
agravamiento del precio de los alimentos
a nivel internacional por la guerra de
ucrania ya teníamos ya salíamos de la
pandemia con un incremento notable del
número de personas en inseguridad
alimentaria tenemos que diferenciar
también de distintos grados de
inseguridad alimentaria tenemos la
inseguridad alimentaria severa que lo
podemos traducir como personas que pasan
el día sin comer y eso ha alcanzado las
cifras de 60 millones de personas en el
conjunto de américa latina y caribe a
finales de 2021 no sabemos todavía ahora
estamos con la labor de medir el impacto
que estas nuevas condiciones están
ocasionando en los precios de los
alimentos y las consecuencias que esto
va a tener evidentemente con un aumento
del número de personas que van a
necesitar asistencia alimentaria y luego
de forma general con algún grado de
inseguridad moderada encontramos hasta
267 millones de latinoamericanos en las
cifras vemos que van subiendo la
pandemia fue algo que impactó sin duda y
la guerra de ucrania también está
haciendo no sólo borrar el aumento de
presión alimento sino también por el
aumento del precio de los combustible
miguel continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda en sentido contrario hablemos
entonces de los factores porque como
ustedes lo han dicho los dos invitados
no es solamente el hecho de haber
comenzado esa invasión de rusia a
ucrania lo que ha llevado a aumentar las
cifras ya contempla la posibilidad de un
aumento en esta crisis alimentaria en la
región de américa latina hay muchos
factores adicionales y sobre todo
factores que la región de américa latina
ya lleva arrastrando desde hace mucho
tiempo como es la pobreza la desigualdad
económica y también la desigualdad en
cuanto al reparto de las tierras
hablemos entonces de esos factores
adicionales que también me gustaría
añadir ahí el cambio climático sobre
todo allí en centroamérica hay serios
problemas con la temporada de huracanes
en países como honduras y bueno y en
nicaragua no usted se encuentra miguel
sin duda el cambio climático es uno de
los factores que también viene agravar
la situación lo que ocurre con el cambio
climático es que son más frecuentes en
fenómenos climáticos extremos entonces
tenemos que sequías más marcadas o
huracanes como ocurrió en el 2020 que
tuvimos dos huracanes de máxima
categoría que en el mes de noviembre
azotaron lo que es la costa de nicaragua
y honduras además de esto existe un
hambre estructural podríamos llamarlo
así en países como guatemala donde el 46
por ciento de los niños tienen
desnutrición crónica
niño menor de 5 años pero esto es algo
que se arrastra a lo largo de la vida
adulta en países como guatemala si con
el hambre estructural porque los
salarios promedio desde las personas que
tienen un empleo el salario promedio
está en torno a los 260 dólares y el
precio de una canasta alimentaria el
precio de lo que cuesta alimentar una
familia en un mes está en torno a los
390 dólares entonces vemos que si en una
familia solo tienen un ingreso solo
entra un salario no son capaces
dedicando íntegramente los ingreso
económico a la compra de alimentos pues
no son capaces de poder comprar todo lo
que requiere desde el punto de vista
alimentación para tener una vida
saludable del punto de vista alimentario
esto implica que no pueden hacer frente
además a otros gastos que son esenciales
gastos de salud carlos de educación
gastos de vivienda
expedito y su opinión en cuanto a los
factores miguel ha destacado el factor
climático pero que otros factores
podemos también poner sobre la mesa que
se añade a esta crisis en ucrania y en
rusia le pongo un uno sobre la mesa como
punto de partida también la
inestabilidad económica y política de
muchos países de la región
y claro la inestabilidad económica y
política de la región es uno de los
factores
que se construye sobre algunos efectos
históricos de inseguridad alimentaria
por ejemplo que se verifica en la región
hemos hablado de pobreza estructural
hemos hablado de altos niveles de
desigualdad el efecto del cambio
climático los altos niveles también de
de inseguridad entonces todo eso crea lo
que yo mencionaba antes esa crisis
compleja que está afectando a las
personas en la región
y entonces estos indicadores que
nosotros monitoreamos de muy de cerca en
el programa mundial de alimentos ya nos
están dando indicaciones de que la
situación se va a empeorar en los
próximos meses y de hecho nosotros hemos
desarrollado un escenario
estadístico según el cual el número se
subirá de 9.3 a 13.3 personas millones
de personas en antigüedad alimentaria
grave se verá entonces un aumento de 4
millones de personas y el conflicto y
las dinámicas económicas a nivel global
sigue en acción
expedito como entonces empezar a atacar
este problema hablemos a nivel de la
región porque me imagino que cada país
tendrá sus complicaciones también
internas y hacen frente a diferentes
situaciones pero por dónde empezar a
atacar entonces este problema por la
parte de la producción económica
de gestión política
por dónde comenzar
bueno la respuesta muy simple es
trabajar muy de cerca con los gobiernos
locales los gobiernos locales en sí
mismo están afectados por el tema de la
pandemia de esta crisis compleja y el
tema de la crisis porque vienen tienen
un espacio fiscal muy reducido por haber
asistido a millones de personas en los
últimos años entonces nosotros estamos
trabajando muy de cerca con los
gobiernos para poder identificar
soluciones específicas por país estamos
dando mucha importancia a los pequeños
agricultores que trabajamos de la mano
con ellos para poder fortalecer las
economías locales
las operaciones del programa mundial de
alimentos también se han visto afectada
en ese sentido porque también el costo
de proveer esa asistencia a esas
personas ha subido y entonces el
programa mundial de alimentos necesita
como más fondos para poder hacer frente
a esa crisis y entonces estamos
trabajando juntamente con todos los
actores a nivel global haciendo mucho
esfuerzo de abogacía también para llamar
la atención en esta región
para poder enfrentar esa crisis hay todo
un tema relacionado con
las dinámicas internacionales y de
algunos países que están más conectados
con los países involucrados en el
conflicto como rusia ucrania en
particular en esta región la influencia
que tienen en la cuba en nicaragua por
ejemplo en venezuela entonces hay
algunos países que necesitan más
atención y eso se suma a la crisis a la
emergencia la gran emergencia que se
verifica en aena y que entonces no sólo
trabajamos de la mano con los gobiernos
para poder
identificar soluciones específicas al
contexto y para empoderar también las
economías locales con nuestros programas
miguel le pregunto por dos casos
puntuales el caso en nicaragua
bueno caso honduras también y ya lo
mencionaba el proyecto también cuba y
venezuela son casos
que son preocupantes para las
organizaciones internacionales cómo está
la situación en nicaragua que es donde
usted se encuentra en donde hay muy poca
información oficial y de donde se puede
también recabar muy pocos datos por el
tipo de gobierno que tienen allí
efectivamente a nivel regional
no solo en nicaragua sino en
especialmente de centroamérica es un
desafío el tener información
actualizada sobre cómo va evolucionando
la situación alimentaria para nosotros
es muy importante el monitoreo
nutricional de los niños es una labor
que hacen contra el hambre como una ong
internacional viene llevando a cabo en
toda la región muy especialmente en
guatemala y esto implica junto con la
autoridades junto con instituciones
públicas hacer un seguimiento
de cuál es ese estado nutricional eso
implica pesar y tallar niños sobre todo
los menores de 5 años que son los más
sensibles a problemas nutricionales y
esto va ligado también como una
respuesta a facilitar una mejora en los
tratamientos de los niños identificados
con desnutrición aguda eso es re
fundamental y eso debe ser una prioridad
en países como guatemala y honduras otra
prioridad deben ser también el impulsar
a todos los gobiernos de la región los
programas de protección social y ahí en
américa latina especialmente
centroamérica en conjunto de
centroamérica tiene una brecha con el
resto con el promedio internacional o
sea los países invierten muy poco dinero
o menos del que deberían en proveer
asistencia básica fundamental por
ejemplo a adultos mayores en los
programas de transferencia económica o
de pensiones son son muy precarios y son
grupos de poblaciones de especial
vulnerabilidad lo mismo también con la
infancia o sea la inversión pública para
infancia situación de riesgo debe ser
una premisa y trabajo de organizaciones
como la nuestra ecuación control hambre
y otras ong internacional de bolt
programa mundial de alimento pues
nuestra labor es apoyar allí donde
existen cuellos de botella y facilitar
la entrega de ayuda humanitaria a los
lugares donde existe una mayor deterioro
de la socia alimentaria
-miguel otros dos casos puntuales de la
región en el caso de colombia y el caso
de brasil porque le pregunto por estos
dos países porque están en procesos
electorales brasil ir a las urnas en
octubre colombia está esperando ir a la
segunda vuelta presidencial y uno no ve
en los programas de los candidatos
hablar de este tipo de crisis
regional o de lo que de ganancias a esta
crisis regional por lo menos en el caso
de colombia a lo largo de la campaña es
muy poco lo que se habló de la
asistencia
alimentaria para las zonas más apartadas
rurales y que están todavía dentro del
foco de la violencia del conflicto
interno de ese país estos dos casos son
preocupantes puede colombia o brasil
tener también un cambio de política
económica que pueda agravar un poco esta
crisis alimentaria cuál es el balance
que ustedes hacen
no me atrevería
a hacer predicción de futuro pero sí que
me parece muy interesante recordar lo
que ocurrió en el 2021 en colombia donde
prácticamente todo el país se paralizó
hubo manifestaciones
y hubo una violencia importante en
amplias zonas del país motivada por una
reforma fiscal que en principio iba a
encarecer productos básicos productos de
primera necesidad y eso desencadenó una
reacción popular que obligó finalmente
al gobierno a suprimir esa reforma
fiscal que como le decía parecía que iba
a tener un impacto sobre todo en el
alimento fundamental entonces quizá
ahora mismo no esté no sea un tema que
está en la mesa de debate político pero
si está latente sin duda tanto en brasil
como en colombia y en la medida que los
precios aumenten la presión será mayor
para los gobiernos y eso no sólo en
américa latina sino a nivel
internacional
y dar soluciones las soluciones a este
problema y expedito pasó a preguntarle
ahora por otro tema importante
relacionado con con esta crisis y es que
también hay evidencia que américa latina
y en el caribe también dicen algunos
organismos internacionales que
claramente hay comida hay capacidad para
producir comida a un alto costo para
muchas personas y eso lleva a que las
personas tengan que consumir alimentos
de menor calidad de una peor calidad eso
también incide en factores de
desnutrición y también incide en el
desarrollo pues de los menores de edad
en cuanto a la calidad de los alimentos
eso cómo se puede mejorar cómo se hacen
a nivel regional para no solamente
garantizar que hay alimentos sino que
también sean de buena calidad y
nutritivos para las personas
por supuesto lo que acabamos de
mencionar es una de las estrategias que
las personas
adoptan para hacer frente a la escasez
de comida las clases de recursos para
poder comprar comida especialmente en un
contexto de inflación como lo que
estamos viviendo
disminuir también la
cantidad de comida que se consume por
día disminuir el número de comida
hacer que los niños coman y que los
adultos renuncien por ejemplo la comida
estas son estrategias que las los
hogares las personas normalmente
utilizan para hacer frente a esta
situación a estas situaciones
como como programa mundial de alimentos
nosotros siempre garantizamos que la
asistencia que nosotros proveemos sea de
la mejor calidad pero también
fortaleciendo la cadena de suministro
locales como decía antes fortaleciendo
el trabajo que hacemos con las
comunidades indígenas con los pequeños
productores
para fortalecer la calidad la cadena de
suministro y para que la gente pueda
consumir comida de calidad y que pueda
consumir comida en general que tenga
acceso a un nivel aceptable de
comida por día de calorías por día y que
pueda eso tener un impacto positivo
sobre la seguridad alimentaria en la
región
expedito y que hay del del modelo de
producción que hay en la mayoría de los
países de américa latina estamos
hablando que primero la tierra está
concentrada en muy pocas manos en muy
pocas familias en monocultivos de
grandes extensiones para producir a gran
escala para poder exportar para poder
generar ingresos y divisas para los
diferentes países esto también sería un
punto de partida tal vez para para
empezar a cambiar la situación
diversificar la forma de cultivo y hacer
una redistribución de tierras o por lo
menos una redistribución de los
productos que no todas las regiones
tengan que cultivar exactamente lo mismo
tenga que ponerse acuerdo y cultivar
exactamente lo mismo
sí por supuesto que sí lo que está
impactando mucho en los país de la
región es también el hecho de que los
países de esa región
son dependientes de la importación de
cereales entonces hay países productores
y países que importan mucho de esos
cereales y eso está haciendo de que
algunos países no pueden acceder a los
mismos niveles de consumo como antes
debido al aumento de precios que estamos
que estamos viviendo lo que lo que
mencionaba antes trabajar muy de cerca
con las pequeñas comunidades
fortalecerla como las pequeñas
comunidades
enfrentar esos problemas de desigualdad
que son problemas estructurales aquí en
la región como comentabas las tierras se
concentran en pocas manos
eso nos hace trabajar muy de cerca con
las comunidades con los pequeños
agricultores para fortalecer el acceso
de estas personas a los mercados locales
para conectarlos con los mercados para
que ellos puedan tener un mayor acceso y
que eso en retorno pueda mejorar también
la diversidad de los cultivos la
diversidad como consecuencia de la dieta
de estas comunidades y que eso pueda
tener un impacto en general sobre el
consumo de alimentos y sobre si la
seguridad alimentaria migueli su opinión
al respecto sobre el modelo de
producción en este modelo que prioriza
las grandes extensiones de un mismo
cultivo para la exportación
bueno además de tener en cuenta el
modelo de producción hay que tener en
cuenta el modelo de sociedad
latinoamericana que es fundamentalmente
urbana el 80 por ciento de los
latinoamericanos viven en ciudades de
más de 20.000 habitantes y eso implica
que buena parte de los latinoamericanos
ya están desvinculados de la actividad
agrícola no son productores sino son
sobre todo personas que viven en medio
urbano y que para alimentarse dependen
del dinero de su salario para poder
comprar alimentos entonces un desafío
fundamental es que los alimentos sean lo
más baratos lo más asequibles posible y
una medida que tendría un impacto
inmediato o un análisis que podría
hacerse para orientar decisiones es todo
aquello que restringe la posibilidad de
comerciar de intercambiar de importar o
exportar alimentos decisiones como la
que ha tomado la india de prohibir las
exportaciones de trigo tiene un impacto
enorme en el mercado internacional y
todo lo que sea favorecer que los
alimentos otro alimentos de primera
necesidad
y entrar y salir de los países para
atender sobre todo donde existen demanda
de alimentos ayuda evidentemente a
quienes tienen menos capacidad de
producción estoy totalmente de acuerdo
que hay que apoyar también a los
pequeños productores pequeños
productores de la medida de lo posible
agrupados en cooperativas
agro-alimentarias que tienen un papel
fundamental en el sistema alimentario de
cualquier país y que nos permiten llegar
de una forma
eficiente a brindar apoyo a esos
productores que ahora lo necesitan más
que nunca entiendo entiendo ese modelo
que usted explica pero eso ya no se ha
intentado en el pasado si ha sido
exitoso si ha logrado tener un impacto o
como tal vez lograr una transición a un
sistema que sea un poco más sostenible
miguel'
bueno la sostenibilidad se puede
entender de distintas formas y una
sostenibilidad ambiental que es esencial
en la forma de producir tener la
capacidad de preservar los recursos tu
recursos de los cuales estás generando
la producción de alimentos que necesitas
tú y que necesita vender porque la
sociedad también lo necesita entonces
eso es fundamental y en lo que se
refiere a la posibilidad de comprar
vender en el mercado internacional
alimento lo cierto es que existen
importantes restricciones es muy
interesante analizar lo que ocurre por
ejemplo en guatemala que es el contexto
nacional que conozco especialmente bien
llama mucho la atención
el flujo permanente de inmigrantes lo
que atraviesa en guatemala en dirección
hacia eeuu pero cuando uno se encuentra
en la frontera de guatemala entre méxico
por ejemplo además de ver migrantes de
distintos países que van hacia el norte
también es interesante observar cómo
vienen alimentos
importados más importados entran de
contrabando a guatemala desde mexico
porque resulta que una diferencia de
presión notable especialmente en
alimentos como lácteos y huevos que son
esenciales en la dieta de los hogares
más vulnerables en guatemala y esos
alimentos son más baratos en méxico y
por tanto entra en la guatemala de forma
de forma irregular y eso se debe a que
el mercado de un país como guatemala
tiene precio que en productos como por
ejemplo la leche están incluso un 50 por
ciento más altos que lo que se encuentra
en méxico entonces facilitar que sobre
todo en los países donde existe mayor
problema alimentario se puedan comprar
alimentos más baratos es un objetivo
fundamental
claro es fundamental expedito hemos
analizado los diferentes factores y
hemos visto esta crisis desde diferentes
puntos de vista pero hay quienes dicen
que en medio de la crisis también está
la oportunidad y también
en este momento de coyuntura una
oportunidad para américa latina para
entrar al mercado internacional
siendo un proveedor de alimentos y otro
tipo de cereales distintos pueden ser
los que producen rusia y ucrania
precisamente por estas sanciones que
pesan sobre rusia la salida de ucrania
del mercado internacional por no poder
ni siquiera recoger las cosechas para
este verano para poderla sacar a través
de sus puertos que están en manos de los
rusos puede américa latina' entrar a
cubrir algunos de esos mercados algunos
de esos puntos y tener ahí una
oportunidad también de negocio digámoslo
así
y seguramente si en cada crisis tenemos
que identificar cuál han sido las
debilidades y trabajar para
fortalecerlas entonces el sistema
productivo lo mencionábamos antes es una
de las debilidades porque los países
necesitan y son dependientes de la
importación de cereales son dependientes
de algunos insumos como fertilizantes
por ejemplo y entonces lo eso eso hace
que los países siguen siendo
dependientes del mercado global entonces
en la crisis hemos identificado
debilidades que tenemos que fortalecer
entonces nuestro trabajo del día a día
nosotros tenemos que fortalecer intentar
las formas mejores para poder
fortalecer esas debilidades
empezando de las comunidades empezando
de las personas que están en inseguridad
alimentaria severa empezando a las
personas que de verdad no pueden acceder
a la comida es la persona que se tiene
que enfrentar todos los días con los
desafíos de lo que está pasando a nivel
global y
haciendo como todo un trabajo que sube a
niveles más altos trabajando juntamente
de la mano con los gobiernos y los
sistemas de protección social -miguel su
opinión sobre la oportunidad que pueda
tener américa latina con esta coyuntura
pues de hecho hay países que van a verse
beneficiados países que son exportadores
de cereales de leguminosas ahí destaca
argentina brasil bolivia también es un
país que puede verse beneficiado y en
términos generales yo creo que sí que es
esencial tener la capacidad de los
propios países de cubrir sus necesidades
de alimentos pero américa latina tiene
esa ventaja de disponer de tierras
agrícolas
que permiten permitirían deberían de
permitir alimentar sobradamente a la
población latinoamericana y poder
exportar y poder contribuir a alimentar
otras partes del mundo que especialmente
en áfrica o lo que sería
oriente medio se van a ver especialmente
afectadas porque dependen de la
importación de cereal de ucrania rusia y
ahí el impacto va a ser enorme por
supuesto ahí ahí entonces mucho espacio
para el sector agrícola
latinoamericano expedito y siendo muy
positivo tal vez en un escenario muy
positivo y pensando muy a futuro puede
américa latina' llegar aún a una
instancia de ser autosuficiente de
lograr por lo menos satisfacer muchas de
sus necesidades alimenticias o
alimentarias en buena parte de la
población esto puede ser un escenario
posible sé que estoy hablando
en un escenario poco fantasioso pero
pero pero podría llegar a suceder
sí claro eso debería suceder porque la
región tiene todas las capacidades para
poderlo hacer
como comentaba antes lo que sí tenemos
que hacer es trabajar sobre los desafíos
estructurales que hay en esta región si
no trabajamos sobre esos desafíos
estructurales como la pobreza que hay en
algunos países como la desigualdad que
mencionábamos antes que la tierra está
concentrada en pocas manos entonces sin
trabajar en hacer la comunidad de más
recipientes frente al impacto del cambio
climático por ejemplo
sin resolver esos problemas
estructurales de base va a ser muy
difícil poder lograr un cambio entonces
para poder lograr ese cambio nosotros
tenemos que trabajar sobre esos impactos
estos tenemos tienen que tener un
impacto los progresos factores
estructurales históricos que han
producido pobreza en esta región la
región de por si tiene todas las
características para poder ser
autosuficiente para que los países
puedan defender de sí mismo para poder
generar la
responder a la demanda interna del
consumo los problemas de raíz son los
que tendrían que empezar a solucionarse
ya lo hemos matizado un poco miguel lo
hemos conversado a grandes rasgos en
algunas de sus intervenciones sobre los
problemas sociales que hay aquí en la
región de américa latina ese posible
escenario de una crisis alimentaria en
algunos de los países de la región que
puede comenzar en cualquier momento esto
también podría desatar o potenciar otros
problemas que ya tienen la región como
por ejemplo las olas migratorias
por ejemplo
inestabilidad política usted mencionaba
el caso de colombia que la gente salga a
las calles porque tiene hambre porque
necesita comer y haya inestabilidad
política de eso lleve a derrocar
gobiernos o por lo menos a tomar medidas
extremas por parte de las autoridades
qué tan factible es que esto pueda
llegar a suceder
nuevamente para hacer una predicción
siempre tenemos que pensar o tenemos que
revisar qué ha pasado con anterioridad
la crisis más parecida podríamos
encontrar la que encontramos actualmente
fue en el 2008 2009 fue una crisis
financiera de aumento del precio del
petróleo también como estamos viendo
ahora y de aumento del precio del
alimento en aquella crisis se produjo un
deterioro de la situación sociopolítica
muy marcado en medio oriente recordarán
lo que son las primaveras árabes en los
años 2009 2010 2011 la guerra de siria
arranca en 2011 todo eso se relaciona
estrechamente con con esa crisis
financiera y con esa crisis de precios
que ocurrió en aquel momento podría
ocurrir en américa latina o en alguno de
los países
situaciones parecidas bueno no podemos
decirlo de manera cierta si sabemos que
aumenta la probabilidad de que sucesos
de ese tipo ocurran y eso imagino que
debe hacer a los gobiernos priorizar
como hicieron la mayoría de ellos
durante la pandemia pues priorizar la
protección social no priorizar el hecho
de invertir
la cantidad más pequeña de ciudadanos se
vea afectada e intentar variar como sea
los efectos más perniciosos del momento
de presión es eso aquí obliga pues a
focalizar muy bien a identificar muy
bien quiénes son los grupos de población
más golpeados por crisis como ésta entre
esos grupos de población se encuentra la
población rural en áreas expuestas
especialmente a cambio climático con muy
poco acceso a tierra con muy poco
ingreso económico adultos mayores en un
grupo de población que experimenta
especialmente las consecuencias del
aumento de precio sobre todo donde no
existen pensiones y lamentablemente eso
es algo que caracteriza a buena parte de
países de latinoamérica no especialmente
de centroamérica ya me quedan pocos
minutos para terminar el programa
expedito también quiero conocer su
opinión sobre este tema la inestabilidad
política que hay acá en los problemas
sociales y la migración por supuesto se
empiezan a entrelazar entonces las
diferentes coyunturas sociales y se
vuelve una gran bola de nieve digámoslo
así que puede llegar a consecuencias muy
graves para la región
si es una crisis compleja como decíamos
antes es una es una mezcla de factores
que está empujando a las personas a
dejar sus países
nosotros observamos un incremento
importante significativo en el número de
personas que están cruzando los países
aquí en la región
y preveemos que ese número pueda subir
significativamente los próximos meses
debido a los factores que están
impactando la economía global y de cómo
eso se están reduciendo a nivel de país
la crisis política es simplemente uno de
los factores que está que caracteriza la
situación en algunos países en la crisis
económica socioeconómica nosotros vemos
también hemos registrado un aumento de
protestas acerca del precio de la de los
precios en general del precio de comida
y de a precio de combustible está
empujando a muchas personas a dejar sus
países para poder encontrar mejor suerte
en en otros los estamos monitoreando muy
de cerca estamos interesados en la
seguridad alimentaria de estas personas
también y lo vamos a montar muy de cerca
en los próximos meses me queda un minuto
para terminar el programa rápidamente
quiero hacer las conclusiones comienzo
con miguel 30 segundos por favor sus
conclusiones que se debe hacer o que se
destaca de esta situación o que se puede
mejorar
bueno pues estamos en un contexto que
necesita una respuesta global una
respuesta regional cuando estamos
hablando de américa latina un compromiso
de los gobiernos como lo tuvimos con la
pandemia donde sí que hubo un esfuerzo
para atender las necesidades
fundamentales y eso lo que no queríamos
también en las por situaciones expedito
rápidamente 20 segundos para su
conclusión
necesitamos un compromiso global estoy
de acuerdo con donde todos los actores
trabajan juntos para poder mejorar esta
situación entonces los actores como
nosotros como el tema como acción contra
el hambre como los gobiernos los
donantes este señor privados las
personas que trabajamos de una forma
global con una visión global para poder
enfrentar este problema al todos les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros y haber hecho este análisis
para la audiencia de france 24
muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado y ustedes muchas gracias por
su sintonía pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]